Transcription: Regis Feve
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Moi, je suis connologue, ça veut dire
que j’étudie la connerie.
Ben quoi, ça concerne plein de gens.
Bon, évidemment pas dans cette salle,
je ne me permettrais pas...
pas dans cette salle.
Enfin…
Pas dans cette salle ?
Bon, euh...
Par acquit de conscience, on va vérifier :
levez la main si...
vous avez déjà fait, dit ou pensé
des conneries, s’il vous plaît,
mais n’ayez pas honte,
ça arrive aux meilleurs.
(rires)
(sursaut de peur)
On m’avait pas prévenu !
Oui, écoutez, vous êtes 1200,
vous ne vous connaissiez pas
et d’un seul coup, vous vous découvrez
un point commun, c’est sympa
Alors maintenant, avec la même sincérité
s’il vous plaît,
levez la main si vous vous définissez
avant tout comme un pauvre con
ou une pauvre conne.
(rires)
C’est pas les mêmes statistiques.
Bon, nous voilà face
à une première énigme de la connologie.
On reconnaît tous
qu’on fait des conneries,
mais le con c’est toujours l’autre.
Mais ça s’explique : moi,
quand je fais des conneries,
c’est par hasard.
C'est un accident.
D’ailleurs, je m’en rends compte.
Je me dis : «Ah ! Quel con ! »
(rires)
Mais oui, Madame, et au moment où je dis
« ah ! Quel con ! », je cesse de l’être
parce que j’ai pris conscience
de mon erreur, je m’en repends.
Je jure qu’on ne m’y reprendra plus,
avec un peu de chance
j’ai appris de cette erreur,
je me coucherai moins bête ce soir,
c’est pas de la connerie, ça.
Tandis que l’autre, le con,
il persiste.
(rires)
Sans s’en rendre compte, sans vouloir
s’en rendre compte, il est content !
Alors moi, je fais des conneries
et lui, il est con.
(rires)
Bon, il y a un peu de complaisance
là-dedans, évidemment.
D'ailleurs, en psychologie, ça s'appelle
le biais de complaisance.
On se trouve des excuses.
C’est un des biais cognitifs,
un des raccourcis de la pensée,
un des automatismes et des réflexes
qu’on met tous en œuvre au quotidien
à notre insu,
quand on se pique de réfléchir.
Évidemment, si on rechigne
à se reconnaître con,
il y a toujours une bonne âme
pour vous le signaler.
On est tous le con de quelqu’un.
Ah oui, mais de qui ?
Il ne faut pas être le
con de n’importe qui !
« Passer pour un idiot
aux yeux d’un imbécile
est une volupté de fin gourmet »,
écrivait Georges Courteline.
Être le con d’un con, tout est là.
Voilà notre gloire, notre consolation.
Être le con d’une bande de cons,
c’est un privilège,
c’est presque trop beau pour être vrai.
Et vous savez, de même qu’on est
tous le con de quelqu’un,
on a tous
un con fétiche.
Un con étalon,
(rires)
un con suprême, notre roi des cons à nous,
c'est strictement personnel.
Tenez, on va faire une expérience.
Fermez les yeux et...
cherchez un con.
Vous allez trouver !
Mais attention, pas n’importe quel con,
pas un brave couillon qui essaie
de faire une conférence TED, non, non.
Le pire vrai sale gros con
que vous connaissiez.
Ou la pire vraie sale grosse conne,
ça marche aussi, rassurez vous.
Alors, ça peut être un con célèbre,
un con de la télé, un polémiste.
(rires et applaudissements)
Un président de la République,
mais pas forcément en France, hein ?
Ça peut être aussi,
de préférence même peut-être,
un connard que vous connaissez
au quotidien,
quelqu’un qui vous fait du mal.
Peut-être un connard au travail,
un connard dans le voisinage.
Un connard dans la famille, ça arrive.
Ca y est vous tenez votre con fétiche
ou votre conne fétiche ?
Bien solidement ?
Alors maintenant,
toujours les yeux fermés,
pensez à cette personne.
Et observez ce qui se passe
dans votre corps.
Vos sourcils se froncent.
Votre mâchoire se crispe.
C'est tout votre corps
qui se réduit un peu.
Votre...
respiration se saccade…
vos battements de cœur s’accélèrent
et cette colère qui monte… cette colère.
Et maintenant, toujours
avec les yeux fermés,
imaginez...
que,
par bonheur,
miraculeusement, d’un coup
de baguette magique,
ce connard ou cette connasse
disparaît à jamais de votre vie.
Plus jamais, plus jamais, plus jamais,
vous ne l’aurez dans les pattes.
Et là, qu’est-ce qui se passe
dans votre corps ?
Aaah...
ça soulage !
On respire, hein, quand même ?
Pfff !
Voilà, on a envie de rigoler un peu.
On est bien sans le con,
on est bien sans tout ce poids,
cette anxiété, ce stress.
On est libéré.
Ouvrez les yeux,
Coucou !
Ça va ? Ça va mieux ?
Vous voyez à quel point
la connerie a un impact
non seulement sur nos pensées,
sur nos ruminations
mais sur notre corps-même.
La connologie est un enjeu
de santé publique.
Et vous avez vu aussi
que vous avez chacun
convoqué un connard
ou une connasse différent
et pourtant, vous avez tous
ressenti la même chose.
Se pourrait-il que
ces sinistres personnages
aient un point commun ?
Lequel ?
Mmm mmm !
Des croyances religieuses ?
Des opinions politiques
qui vous déplaisent ?
Ça n’épuise pas le sujet.
À défaut,
un comportement que vous refusez
de voir se développer en vous.
Ah, c’est peut-être
une meilleure piste, ça !
L’arrogance ?
Levez la main si votre con ou
votre conne fétiche
se croit supérieur aux autres
et peut-être vous méprise en particulier.
C’est pas mal, ça, hein ?
Ouais, ben oui, le con a le melon.
(rires)
Le con comprend pas grand-chose,
mais il a tout compris.
Le con a une opinion sur tout et comme
il confond son opinion avec le savoir,
le con sait tout.
En plus, il ne retient que
ce qui confirme ses opinions.
Le reste, il le nie, il le minimise.
Ça s'appelle le biais de confirmation.
Alors le con sait tout.
Le con a tout compris à la politique,
« Ben moi, si j’étais au pouvoir... »
Le con a tout compris à la science,
surtout depuis le COVID.
(rires)
Le con a tout compris à la société
dans son ensemble,
avec des bonnes catégories
sur lesquelles coller des stéréotypes,
des clichés, hein ?
« De toute façon, les politiques...
toute façon, les femmes...
toute façon les jeunes...
toute façon les vieux.... »
Il fait aussi des super catégories.
« Toute façon, tout va mal. »
- Ça, c’est le biais de négativité -
« puis de toute façon...
- j’adore celui là -
... toute façon, il y a jamais
eu autant de cons ! »
Vous avez remarqué ?
Les “de toute façon”,
c’est des conneries, de toute façon.
Et puis, le con a tout compris à vous.
Il vous connaît mieux que vous-même !
Le con sait mieux que vous
ce que vous devez faire de votre vie.
Le con sait mieux que vous,
quelles émotions, de joie ou de colère
vous pouvez vous permettre ou non.
Le con sait mieux que vous
de quoi vous devez rire ou non.
qui vous pouvez aimer.
En quoi vous devez croire ou non.
Et ces opinions sont définitives,
lapidaires, infaillibles.
En un mot, la certitude rend con !
Et ça, j’en suis sûr !
(rires)
(applaudissements)
Le con souffre de ce que les Grecs, déjà,
qualifiaient d’hubris.
La certitude tout à fait injustifiée
de ne pas être n’importe qui
et que les autres font n’importe quoi
et que tout nous est dû.
Et si encore le coup était seul !
Mais comme disait Frédéric Dard,
« si tous les cons volaient,
il ferait nuit ! »
(rires)
Et des nuées et des nuées de connards
se regroupent au mieux en troupeau,
au pire en meute.
Et le monde crève de ces andouilles
qui se prennent au sérieux
et qui vous donnent des leçons
au lieu de montrer l’exemple.
Et c’est comme ça que des communautés,
des cultures, des sociétés parfois
sont frappées d’hubris,
se déclarent supérieures
et décident que les autres
doivent se soumettre
ou disparaître.
En tout cas, être traités en ennemi.
Or, que faire face à un con
qui vous traite en ennemi ?
Tirer le premier ?
Non, on peut pas le tuer,
le pauv’ con, quand même.
Non, non, non, non, non, on ne tue
pas le con, on se ferait prendre.
Bon, alors, à défaut, est-ce qu’on peut
le désarmer, le convaincre de sa connerie,
lui faire prendre conscience, le guérir ?
Alors là, je me permets
de vous mettre en garde.
Le con ne veut pas entendre raison.
Le con veut avoir raison.
Et qu’est-ce qui se passe
sur les réseaux sociaux, par exemple,
si vous essayez de guérir un con ?
Qu’est-ce qu’il vous répond ?
« Ah je gêne,
mais tu ne me feras pas taire,
je suis un résistant ! »
Ben voilà, vous l’avez renforcé.
Et pire encore,
là où il y avait un con,
en voilà deux.
Parce que vous, après tout,
de quel droit
le changer ?
Pour qu’il ressemble à qui ?
Ben à vous bien sûr !
parce que
c’est une définition possible du con.
Le con, c’est celui que JE juge
moins bien que moi.
Le con, c’est le pauvre bougre
qui a le malheur de ne pas me ressembler.
Le con, c’est celui qui me déçoit.
Le con, c’est celui qui est
encore plus con que moi
et avec sa connerie, pas la mienne.
Peut-être qu’en jugeant comme ça,
moi aussi je fais preuve
de jugement définitif,
lapidaire, infaillible.
Peut-être que je confonds mon opinion
sur le con avec un savoir.
Peut-être que
si je jugeais moins les gens,
la connerie disparaîtrait.
Pas parce que j’aurais guéri les cons,
que je les aurais soumis, mais parce que
j’arrêterais de les créer avec mon regard.
Moi-même, je suis extrêmement sévère
avec mon con fétiche, le pauvre.
Tiens, je vais vous dire qui c'est.
Non… si, je vais vous dire qui c’est.
Le connard qui m’aura le plus pourri
l’existence, et de loin,
c’est moi.
C'est moi.
Qu’est-ce que j’ai pu me gâcher
comme chances et comme possibilités !
Qu’est-ce que j’ai pu me rendre
malheureux tout seul !
Et rendre malheureux
les gens qui m’aimaient.
Malgré tout, les cons.
Qu’est-ce que j’ai pu me gâcher la vie !
Et il arrive un moment où te dire
« Ah quel con », ça ne suffit plus.
Il arrive un moment où chercher un con,
c’est-à-dire chercher un coupable,
ça revient à oublier
que tu es responsable aussi.
Bon, alors n’exagérons rien,
j’ai jamais volé , j’ai jamais violé,
j’ai jamais tué personne, même pas
des cons, donc je m’en sors plutôt bien.
Ça pourrait être pire.
Ma vie pourrait être pire.
Je pourrais perdre mes cheveux en plus.
Et puis, ce qui me console, c’est que
je ne suis pas tout à fait un cas isolé.
Complaisance à part,
on porte tous un peu
le virus de la connerie
avec une fièvre plus ou moins contagieuse.
Des symptômes plus ou moins visibles,
plus ou moins invalidants
pour soi et pour les autres.
Des symptômes, il y en a plein.
Comment j’ai pu être assez con
pour gâcher ce bel amour
qui signifiait tellement pour moi ?
Ça parle à quelques-uns ?
Comment j’ai pu être assez conne
pour tomber amoureuse de ce connard.
Ca parle à quelques-unes ?
Comment j’ai pu être assez con
pour ne pas voir grandir mes enfants ?
Comment j’ai pu être assez conne
pour passer à côté de mon père
pendant des années,
sous prétexte qu’il n’était pas assez bien
pour moi, maintenant il est mort.
Comment je peux être assez con
pour rester dans ce job de merde
alors que je vaux mieux que ça ?
Comment je peux être assez conne
pour passer des heures et des heures
tous les jours à regarder
des conneries sur les écrans
alors que  j’ai qu’une vie, elle m’attend
et je suis en train de lui poser un lapin.
Vous voyez, quand on s’éloigne
des certitudes générales,
à quel point on bascule facilement
dans le doute particulier ?
Comme on se languit d’un tout petit peu
de cohérence,
un tout petit peu de sens pour soi.
C’est l’affaire de toute une vie
et c’est douloureux.
Connais-toi toi-même !
Y compris, et peut-être surtout
dans ta part de connerie.
Pour te pardonner, ce qui relève
des erreurs, des errances, des échecs,
des petites imperfections humaines,
mais pour prendre à bras le corps
cette connerie plus solidement,
plus durablement,
plus profondément enracinée,
qui, dans le fond,
te rend malheureux et rend malheureux
les autres par ricochet, tu le sais bien.
Seulement, bon courage
pour t’aventurer dans le labyrinthe
personnel de la connerie.
Il y a beaucoup d’entrées,
beaucoup de culs-de-sac.
Il y a peut être une sortie.
Mais j’ai pas trouvé.
Je tourne encore.
Et puis, j’ai pas fini de tourner
et franchement,
il y a des jours où c’est fatigant.
Moralité ?
Moralité, la certitude rend con,
le doute rend fou.
Choisis ton camp.
Merci.